hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we
start morning
spoilers ahead today i'm gonna explain
an american superhero and fantasy movie
called underdog
in the capital city hall there is a man
showing the unsolved crime files he
seems to be the mayor of the city there
are also trained dogs that are used to
assist the police
a beagle on the police bomb squad named
alpha dog suddenly barks because he
smells something in one of the boxes
as a result everyone in the room is
immediately secured out of the building
meanwhile the police and swat are sent
to the room to check the contents of the
box
it turns out that it was just a piece of
meat consequently everyone in the room
laughs at alpha dog as well as the other
dogs who start to mock him at last
the embarrassed alpha dog instantly
leaves the building
outside he takes off his police uniform
and starts walking aimlessly
suddenly a man takes him somewhere and
locks him up in a cage
there he meets a hairless dog and asks
him what this place is
the hairless dog replies that during the
day this place is a dog sanctuary while
at night everything will be different
the scene moves into a man named dan
unger who wants to go to work he works
as a security guard in a research
laboratory not long after dr simon comes
to the place he is a genetic scientist
even though the lab is already closed dr
simon is still allowed in as he has full
access to the laboratory then he is
escorted by his assistant named
cadillacky they arrive at a room where
alpha dog is located and nearby is a
fairly large laboratory bitter that his
proposal for genetic experimentation was
declined earlier dr simon plans to prove
the mayor wrong by testing his new serum
on alpha dog cat then takes alpha dog
from the cage
since cad doesn't keep an eye on him he
immediately tries to escape from the lab
chaos begins to occur until he is
spilled by various kinds of chemical
liquids
dr simon notices something strange
happening to alpha dog's body
surprisingly he is able to break the lab
door and escape from the place
on the other hand dr simon is happy and
says that his research has been
successful but unfortunately he has to
be hit by the monitor and a fire breaks
out in the lab
after his escape alpha dog is able to
avoid an encounter with a rottweiler
named riffraff and his lackeys who want
to beat him up while he is running away
a car accidentally hit him from the
front but thanks to the serum he is
unharmed it turns out that it is dan who
hit him just now then he decides to take
alpha dog home seeing that he is so cute
the next morning jack unger dan's son is
seen writing a fake hospital permit not
to go to school
after a while dan calls him from outside
and shows him the alpha dog that he
brought last night he also names him
shoeshine after the dog licks his shoes
however jack becomes jealous of
shoeshine's attention it is revealed
that dan retired from the police to
spend more time with jack after his
wife's death but he still seems busy
lately
afterwards jack leaves for school and
dan goes to work leaving shoeshine at
the house alone
at that time he still does not realize
his new powers
thus he accidentally makes a very large
mess
after coming home jack is surprised
because his house became so messy he
then complains as he cleans up the house
after that the guilt-ridden shoeshine
approaches him and apologizes because it
was an accident at first jack thinks it
was his father's voice but then he
realizes that it was his dog's voice
they are both shocked causing jack to
run away from the house
after they reach a park jack and
shoeshine are talking about the
weirdness earlier on the other hand
shoeshine is also confused why jack
understood what he was saying before
shortly after they bond over their
respective attraction to molly and polly
jack's school friend and her dog
after the girls leave jack
unintentionally finds a frisbee in the
trash and throws it at shoeshine then he
is amazed by shoeshine's incredible
speed
jack also tests his other skills and
discovers that he has super strength
hearing and smell in the process
in fact he can hear that now molly and
paulie are being robbed he tells jack
about it and they head straight for it
on his way shoeshine discovers that he
also can fly
he becomes shocked as he is not able to
control his new flying ability
in the end he discreetly rescues them by
defeating the robbers and mali calls the
police about the robbery
later he returns home with jack making
him promise to never reveal his powers
in front of anyone else
they try to clean the house as soon as
possible before dan goes home
shortly after cad shows up at the door
with posters of shoeshine but jack
manages to fool him into leaving just
before dan comes home and discovers the
mess
meanwhile dr simon and cat are looking
for a way to recreate the serum they
finally find a new layer beneath the
city and also plan a robbery there to
fund rebuilding of the former laboratory
the following day jack says that his
school baseball team has always been the
underdog
shoeshine is initially confused as to
what the word meant but then jack
explains the words to him he also buys a
book on how to train a dog for his
manners
because he has superpowers shoeshine
easily carries out the orders such as
sitting lying down and rolling over as a
gift jack gives him a caller with his
name and jack's home address on it
at night jack tells the story about his
father who has received an award from
the mayor for his bravery they suddenly
see cats heist on the news
because of this jack convinces shoeshine
to intervene the robbery just like
saving molly and paulie previously
at first he is reluctant but in the end
he agrees with jack
arriving there shoeshine disguises
himself as a fish and finally manages to
save the hostages dr simon who sees his
action through the monitor immediately
informs cad that the dog was his
previous experimental subject but
because of his super strength cat
chooses to escape from the place
the following day shoeshine's heroic
action last night is reported on the
news
however he feels unhappy about it
because he doesn't want his identity to
be revealed
jack has an idea and then suggests him
to adopt the alias underdog and becomes
the city's resident superhero while
donning a shrunken red sweater in blue
capes disguise
his actions begin to spread widely both
in the newspapers and in the news
on the other hand molly is gathering
evidence to find out who underdog is
furthermore the mayor also announces to
commemorate underdog day on a certainty
meanwhile dr simon repeatedly fails to
recreate his serum he desperately sends
cad to obtain a sample of underdogs dna
then cad disguises himself as an old
woman who needs help
he falls from the top of the building
and at the right moment underdog manages
to save him
he uses the opportunity to tie the rope
to his collar underdog eventually
realizes that the person is cat without
further ado he is able to run away from
kat
kent fails to capture him but obtains
his collar which contains his secret
identity's name and address
later on shoeshine is rebuffed by polly
but he finally gets a date with her as
underdog
soon dr simon and cat are able to kidnap
dan at his house when jack and underdog
visit molly's house
at his laboratory dr simon forces dan to
call underdog for help
underdog who hears dan's help
immediately alerts jack and they attempt
to save him when they get there dan is
still surprised when he knows that
shoeshine can talk like a human
unluckily dr simon uses both jack and
dan as hostages to convince underdog to
give up his dna
he synthesizes underdog superpowers into
pills and injects shoeshine with an
antidote to the serum turning him into a
normal dog
besides that he also feeds the super
pills to three trained german shepherds
causing them to have superpowers as well
he and cat leave the family trapped in
the sewers
fortunately dan's police experience
allows him to free everyone they pursued
dr simon with a hypodermic needle filled
with the antidote serum
at the city hall dr simon is able to
take the mayor hostage
he also instructs cad to attach a bomb
rig with a mind control serum to the
roof while molly and polly quietly
follow him from behind
outside shoeshine still can smell the
bomb
by conquering his self-doubt he finally
enters the building despite having lost
his superpowers
unfortunately cad discovers molly and
polly he then captures them and ties
them up during a scuffle with dr simon
shoeshine accidentally rips open his
pocket causing his super pills to
scatter on the floor
thus he immediately swallows a super
pill restoring his powers as before
underdog temporarily incapacitates the
german shepherds after he hears molly
and polly call for help but at the same
time dr simon ingests a pill and
distracts him by tossing a shield like a
frisbee
when the german shepherds recover
underdog convinces them to turn on dr
simon who has not treated them well all
this time
while they restrain dr simon the
underdog comes out of the building and
asks jack for his costume after a moment
the mayor manages to get out from the
building
seeing the opportunity dan asks the
mayor to reinstate and promote him so he
can inject dr simon with the antidote
while arresting him
on the other side underdog appears on
the roof and saves molly and polly
instructing them to take the mind
control serum to the police while he
gets the bomb out of harm's way he then
takes the bomb and buries it deep
underground just before it explodes
he tries to escape but unluckily he gets
caught in the explosion launching him
into space
sadly he is presumed dead when he falls
back from outer space
amidst a mournful crowd he unexpectedly
revives leaving everyone overjoyed at
the end
later dan is reinstated officially as a
police officer dr simon and kat are
arrested for their crimes and shoeshine
continues to protect the city as
underdog
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching